la ville de léry veut protéger cet
immense boisée d'environ un kilomètre
carré
mais la petite municipalité située tout
juste à côté de châteauguay n'en a pas
les moyens
le propriétaire réclame 40 millions de
dollars pour céder son terrain à la
ville de 48 millions nous autres
l'estimé de la ville ici c'est à peu
près 3 millions
disons quand on arrive à point qui dit
20 millions de livres pro 20 millions
pour l'acheter l'on trouve le
propriétaire veut obtenir un
dédommagement qui tient compte de la
valeur que sont air y aurait si des
maisons étaient construites mais avec un
peu plus de 2000 résidants et un budget
annuel d'à peine 4 millions de dollars
les villas pas les reins assez solides
le boisé est en péril si demain j'étais
seul incident foraine c'était moi qui
protégeait avec les soude ville de léry
on sera capable ce sera fini on mettre à
terre une forêt qui a toutes sortes de
belles choses de dieu la préservation
des espaces naturels c'est fondamental
pour être en mesure de protéger
davantage de milieux naturels les 82
villes du grand montréal réclame des
modifications à la loi sur
l'expropriation
elles veulent que les dédommagements
faire aux propriétaires soient calculées
selon la valeur marchande des terrains
et non selon leur valeur potentielle
s'il était développé c'est un obstacle
pour conserver des boisés et ont demandé
au gouvernement d'y remédier et de
reconnaître dans le cas de conservation
de terrain on puisse utiliser la juste
valeur marchande faut amener maintenant
les industries du moins le milieu
immobilier conomique embarquer dans le
train parce que on peut plus penser le
développement territorial comme avant au
cabinet de la ministre des affaires
municipales
on dit qu'on va étudier les propositions
de la communauté métropolitaine de
montréal
un groupe de travail sera mis sur pied
il se livrait bachand un réseau au
canada
leyrit